say i have ten thousand dollars say you  have ten thousand dollars okay we are  both 25 years old both of us have ten  thousand dollars i choose to put my ten  thousand dollars in an account that  gives me three percent  you choose to put ten thousand dollars  in an account that gives you twelve  percent it's only four times more so  meaning whatever you get you should only  be four times more than i should be  right so let's take a look at what our  money looks like 24 years later 24 years  later my ten thousand dollars barely  becomes twenty thousand dollars you  ready your ten thousand dollars is  officially a hundred and sixty thousand  dollars that's eight times more even  though the interest is four times more  now let's continue to go 48 years and  see what happens  24 years after that my twenty thousand  becomes forty thousand you ready to see  what happens to 160 000 it is now 2.56  million dollars that's 2.52 million  dollars more than